hey remember that AI generated animation
by Corridor that stirred up some trouble
a few months back well wouldn't you
believe it they're back at it again
of course causing another uproar on the
internet and one element A lot of people
are missing is that they train their
model off of an artist that they paid to
produce character sheets for so it's no
longer morally bankrupt to use AI to
generate and produce off the backs of
millions of stolen pieces of art except
that you know they are releasing this
right in the middle of an historic
animators union strike of whom are
specifically striking against this sort
of thing and also that they now have a
permanent ability to replicate that
artist's work via the model without any
legal obligation to pay them in the
future I'm sure someone in the comments
will say well the artist agreed to the
terms but not only do I think that is an
asinine argument to begin with but is
this really worth fighting for does this
really mean anything